[Music]
Charlie is in Nashville hey Charlie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
taking my call sure what's up well I've
got me some advice on how to start a
budget with my wife more money gotta
control when I can't handle money you
know very well okay
it means whenever we start to talk about
bills or starting a budget we sometimes
just start arguing that would make you a
normal married couple most of us have
okay and so I think the thing is this
what you need to do is both of you have
a vote on the final budget
okay principle principle number one is
we're going to do what's called a zero
based budget and a zero based budget
simply means you're gonna sit down and
April is coming up okay we're gonna look
at April how often are you paid once a
week and how often is she paid once a
week okay so you look at the calendar in
April and you can even do the remaining
of March and all of April if you want
though you could do a month and a half
budget if you want to and say how many
checks are we gonna have during that
period of time how many went so many
Fridays or whatever it is your payday is
right and and what are our checks you
don't Thursday actually okay window what
day did she get paid Thursdays okay so
you just look at Thursday's and say how
many Thursdays if I got during this
month so I got four CH I got four checks
oh I got five checks on the table okay
and then you you add up your total
income for the month take-home pay
take-home pay okay and that's at the top
of the page now all a budget is is the
two of you are going to spend that on
paper every dollar of it it's going to
go to some category on paper on purpose
and you're going to agree to it and then
we're going to stick to whatever we both
vote on and agree to so okay you start
with food I recommend when you very
first start a budget that you break out
grocery stores and restaurants
separately because because the
restaurants will eat your grocery store
budget if you're not careful okay so two
different lines for food you put a
dollar amount beside that that you both
like and agree to then you put lights
and water and gas if you heat with gas
right that canvas so your utilities are
second and and then you pay your house
payment or your rent you got a car
payments okay you have you got car
payments yeah we got to okay you put the
car payments on there we don't have a
house payment okay put the car payments
on there and so your income minus these
dollar figures starts to we're going to
spend it all right down the list okay
and then when you get you really don't
have any argument because you both know
you got to buy food you might argue
about what you're gonna spend on it you
don't have an argument about the car
payments you're either gonna pay the car
payment or they're gonna take it right
there's no arguing there there's no
arguing on paying the light bill you're
gonna pay it or you're gonna be sitting
in the dark you know so you can't really
argue about that the arguments always
come of when there's money past
necessities pass the bills we know we
have to pay how are we going to do that
what are we gonna do with that and
that's where we recommend couples get on
the baby steps plan and you've got goals
then of what you're going to do with any
money we can squeeze out of the budget
what are we going to do well we want you
to have a thousand dollars saved as soon
as you can as your starter emergency
fund and then we want you to start
working your way out of debt in baby
step two where you list your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one and any
money we can squeeze out of the budget
we throw extra at the little one until
it's paid off so we're gonna work our
way out of debt is one of our big goals
for for you because if you don't have
any payments you've got money what
you're going to experience charlie is
this don't argue about a bunch of little
stuff don't argue about $50 on the on
the food budget lose that battle to win
the war and the war is if you guys will
learn to work together on money and it
takes a little while some of the biggest
fights you'll have ever have in your
life are the first two months that you
this budget that's the only Fox we have
yeah but once you get in a rhythm and
you've got an agreement of where we're
going and how that means how we're going
to use any money we can find the other
thing you're going to experience when
you do the budget is you're gonna feel
like you've gotten a raise because when
the money is not got a plan it just runs
away it leaves and when you start we're
doing what I'm talking about you're
gonna look at this and go where is all
our freaking money been going cuz you're
gonna have money left at the bottom of
this I know you are okay okay and then
you guys begin to say okay we want to
get out of debt we want to save for
retirement we want to go on vacation she
needs a new car we need to get the cars
paid off we want to I don't care what
you want to do all i care is that you
agree on it and do it on purpose and
I'll give you a guideline on what I
think you ought to do called the baby
steps but your first step is give every
dollar a name on paper on purpose be in
agreement and then that's a contract you
initial the bottom of it you know and
you pinkie swear and spit shake and
that's a contract you do not spend money
that is not on this budget she does not
spend money that is not on this budget
we are agreeing that this is how we as a
couple are gonna live this month and
it's not you telling her what to do
it's not her telling you what to do you
both have a vote the the contract is
done now the contract tells you both
what to do okay and that'll help you
with your communication processes now
who's the saver and who's the spender
she always says that she's the saver and
I'm the spender I'll call you agree okay
cool so you know what's gonna happen is
is you're gonna want to put stuff in
there too high and she's gonna want to
put stuff in there too low okay sound
like oh well I could do a lot of fun
stuff and then pay my bills
well you're gonna do it the other way
because if you're ever gonna get out of
debt and build wealth the fun stuff is
gonna be towards the bottom of the list
after you get your debts paid off okay
your being debt the rest of your life by
and toys doing fun stuff we always say
adults
vizor plan and follow a children do what
feels good okay so just have a plan but
you can put fun in the budget you're
there to make sure fun is in the budget
she's there to make sure you guys don't
run out of money and have to eat Alpo
okay
that's you're not God put you together
because you're opposites and that's a
perfect way of doing it and so yeah and
so if you'll get a I'm a spender like
you are charlie
and that's why God has me teach this
every day and I figured out the more I
got control of the money the more money
I had to enjoy and to give but I had to
live like no one else so that later I
could live and give like no one else so
the other thing you can do for doing the
budget is check the every dollar go to
every dollar calm and download the every
dollar app it's a very easy budgeting
system that we built it's completely
free you can download it for your phone
for your desktop whatever every dollar
calm you give every dollar a name that's
a zero based budgeting concept and hold
on I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover and if both of
you will read that and both of you will
get an agreement you'll be able to have
fun she'll be able to have to save and
the more she saves the more fun you'll
be able to have because it takes more
you know you can do nice stuff when you
got a bunch of money and you don't get a
bunch of money accidentally you know
becoming rich is never an accident it
always happens on purpose so hey good
question
gonna talk to you I think you're gonna
do great hold on Kelly I'll pick up
we'll get you a copy of the Total Money
Makeover book and get you heading in the
dry right direction